und dann kam so ein mädchen hinterher
gelaufen sie ja ich habe gestern vier
stunden und heute die nummer fünf
stunden angestanden
ich komme aus österreich und ich hab's
pinsel angefahren nur um dich und die
anderen minecraft zu sehen und ich habe
nur von irgendwie von regeln sollten
autogramm bekommt von den anderen alle
nicht und dann meist die kritik zu mir
schon so jahr hat die so ein bisschen
weg geschubst herkommen mit weiter nicht
stehen bleiben sonst müsstest du für
jeden stehen bleiben und dann höre ja
immer ich habe versucht so viel zu
machen wie ich konnte
hallo ich meine lieben freunde herzlich
willkommen zu einer runde hide and seek
auf dem mailserver die ip von der
beschreibung zusammen mit l p midcap hey
hallo ihr lieben und wir haben das extra
in dieser konstellation gedacht dass wir
das aufnehmen der sich den kämpfen
angesichts der kämpfe ist online bei
skype gegangen schreibe ich nochmal an
weil okay wir sind beide heidel was ich
muss mich erstmal ganz klassischer
auswählen ich hab den instant theiler
gpb gelesen wer kann sicher ins tal in
den block verwandeln ich habe einen swap
haider ich weiß nicht was der kantate
anteil von spam
ich weiß ich weiß nicht was mich hinein
was ich bin ein sucher ich bin handel
besucher
ach ich hab ich kann ich kann changing
was ich für eine form bin alles klar
dann suche ich hoffe die fans ich bin
ich bin okay ich sage nicht was ich bin
wahrscheinlich findet doch ich bin etwas
was man essen kann dann gehe ich nun mal
kein titel weizen oder sowas weizen alte
als ob man sich in weit zu verwandeln
kann
ok wat also wir was ich sagen wollte wir
haben uns gedacht okay wir suchen uns
einen schäbigen modus raus und zwar
spielen wir gerade halten sieg und das
leider bis jetzt
handball ist ein bisschen blöd aber wir
wollten über ein thema reden und zwar
die gamescom und die video days und wie
wir das ganz miterlebt haben weil er
auch sehr viele leute von euch waren ich
möchte erstmal das wort geben dass du
ganz gut sagt an welchen tagen nur da
warst und ob du autogrammstunde hattest
und so was alles also sagt dass man mich
ja ich war nämlich an fast jedem tag da
ich bin am mittwoch relativ spät
gekommen aber ich war dann halt am
mittwoch auf der gamescom am donnerstag
war ich oft
gamescom freitag auch am samstag war ich
noch video day
es war so gewesen dass bei mir echt die
termine zur abwechslung als beim letzten
jahr richtig alles vor organisiert war
das heißt ich hatte wirklich am mittwoch
viele termine wo ich spiele angeguckt
habe nebenbei einfach irgendwie gang zu
den fans und am donnerstag war das so
gewesen dass ich beim turnier java und
bei google event das bedeutet das heißt
da hat mich auch bei der bühne in den
fans autogramme geben können
am freitag wieder vor der gamescom
irgendwo einfach immer hingestellt und
dann mit den fans einfach geschnappt und
am samstag auf dem video day
okay das heißt so war es quasi die
komplette zeit da anwesend außer jetzt
am sonntag bereich schon zu hause also
ok ja bei mir war es so dass ich am 13
schon aus dem urlaub zurück gefahren
am 14 dann auf der gamescom war dort war
dann so ein google lager dingsbums da
war es hier auch ja genau diese morgens
veranstaltung so zu sagen was können die
menschen überhaupt seien fast überhaupt
nichts die können mehr lohnen seien
beispielsweise können schweine seien
schweine auch negative allgemeinen die
können auch ganz normal hat andere
blöcke seien
ich glaube aber auch gar die ganze zeit
immer mal so ein bisschen rum was glaube
ich blöd war niemand im moment und da
war ich halt am 14
und dann war ich dann auch auf der
gamescom aber es war halt wirklich sowie
war dann im pressebereich der gamescom
in presse eingang nord war das glaube
ich und es gab relativ viele presse
eingang ost vor beispielsweise das mit
google dieses kleine treffen um ein paar
sachen über youtube noch gelernt hat und
sich mit anderen leuten austauschen
konnte wo wir uns bald beispielsweise
auch gesehen haben ja dann war ich wie
gerade schon gesagt in diesem
pressebereich und man muss echt sagen
ich hab mir gedacht okay kommt games
kommt es vielleicht nicht so krass war
halt so 90 leute sind die sich wirklich
nur für die spieler interessiert nicht
so sehr für die youtuber aber waren im
pressebereich oben die ganze zeit haben
mit leuten aus anderen netzwerken
gequatscht
leuten denen netzwerke die das so alles
da regeln und blabla ein paar termine
hatten wir da und dann sind wir einfach
runter gegangen also revier opels max
und ich und dann standen wirklich vom
pressebereich so viele leute dass
deutschen security ankam und das witzige
war halt wirklich wir sind aus dem
bereich rausgegangen aus diesem
pressebereich kam die security person zu
mir an sondern älterer typ der ein 60
jahre alter also meine enkel schauen
dich dürftig ein foto mit ihm machen
dann macht dieser 16 und dieser
60-jährige dass ein samsung galaxy s 5
raus oder wasserratten und macht sonst
cell viel mit mir und droht pilz und so
und das war schon ganz witzig aber noch
die anderen fenstern sind wir halten so
ein bisschen weg gegangen von den ganzen
anderen darf und haben dann dann
autogramme gegeben muss das ganze aber
nach einer halben stunde abbrechen weil
das zu voll wurde und wir dann noch nie
arena hatten und so fand sich diese
gamescom schön fand ist der umstand dass
es einfach nur mit den security-leuten
schöner geregelt war er letztes jahr die
ersten änderungen an fans irgendwie
bekommen oder sogar keine security da
und das war irgendwie nicht optimal
ja aber dieses jahr was genau in der
gamescom 20 meter aus dem presse wird
euch raus gekommen ist auch kein problem
ich freue mich wenn die leute da sind
und dann waren wir mitten auf dem kann
ich die kritik sind einfach von selbst
gekommen haben wir gesagt ja komm wir
haben ja immer so eine kleine reihe und
haben das einfach von sich aus selbst
durchorganisiert und ich hab dann
sozusagen was wesentlich entspannt damit
den leuten zusammen machen können und
das eigentlich voll cool
ja das war auch gut also diese ganze
organisation
bei der gamescom war echt super dass er
unglaublich viel security leute waren
und auch beim video day zum video denke
ich mal gleich noch eben den games
kommen tag zum abschließen wir sind dann
halt noch ein bisschen rum gelaufen
sondern mit anderen leuten getroffen
immer ab und andere natürlich fans
getroffen und zuschauer und ich habe
wirklich immer versucht alle leute
autogramme zu geben manchmal war es
einfach nicht möglich zum beispiel ein
anderer typ der kam halt wirklich
einfach nur an um eine jak anja
autogramm da kam direkt sieg juli wir
haben das vorhin schon mit einer ankommt
kommen ins spiel und hatten so weg
geschubst das tut mir leid da kann ich
nichts für aber das war auf jeden fall
games kontakt und jetzt eigentlich war
das video ich hab ja dann einfach weg
geschubst
das sieht man höre ich eben im video von
den antrieb man das auch dass diese 70
julia manchmal handgreiflich wurde
nein nein man ja egal ich bin ich auch
eine hand ja ja wir haben schon nebenbei
paar leute getötet also wie gesagt hat
die haben so ein bisschen was von haider
bist du etwas von hunter kann aber das
kommt ja auch nicht ich ihnen die türen
rein und hat sich versteckt in einem
haus ja keine ahnung also die wurden hat
man ja so ein bisschen angreift ich aber
allen und allem was eigentlich ganz gut
dass da so für security auf jeden fall
am start verholfen hat aber ich muss
sagen video da was im fans angeht und
autogramme schöner finster ja weil bei
mir war es zumindest so es war ja anders
als beim letzten jahre war das alles
irgendwie larifari und dieses jahr war
es tatsächlich so dass von anfang an
wurde mir gesagt kev hier
denn was im letzten jahr gesehen kriegs
gleich einen eigenen betreuer
ich habe eigenen betreuer und ein
security das heißt waren zwei leute die
mich immer sozusagen beobachtet haben
oder verfolgt haben und für gesorgt
haben dass alles halt idee ist also das
was kurse dieser eine frau die mit dem
zelt saß ja genau der des securities and
effect nicht gekommen aber da war meine
freunde mit mir dabei und dann meine
aufpasste lausanne lady aus eisen als
ich muss mich mal auf die uhr gucken und
mussten wir nicht zwischen etwas zu
essen holen oder sowas
als sie hat seinem tisch organisiert
oder wie auch immer habe ich gesagt ja
ich würde gerne hierbleiben soziales
gleich um auch kurzfristig jemanden her
damit ihr aufpassen und das war
eigentlich so ganz cool
ja ich aber geräumt ich weiß nicht wir
machen einfach noch eine runde ganz kurz
klar
so warten wir gehen mal einfach bieten
indem welchen nehme ich da nicht immer
den instant haider so will ich aber hier
haider sein und mich
ich glaube doch dass ich mich wieder
einen blog verwandeln kann wie ich will
ja eigentlich ganz geil
das war dieser weg ist im moment zweiter
ritter kannst du einfach sagen ich mal
richtig auf den block und bin an der
blog dass ein ganz cool deshalb wie bei
proplanta das ist echt ganz cool
also ja um zu dem video days zu kommen
muss ich erst mal sagen als ich hatte
zwei stunden die wurden mir irgendwie
volksstück ja und zwar
freitag war das unserem samstag und das
war erstmal so also am freitag bin ich
um 10 uhr mesz zugegangen
dann hat man erst mal diese heftig lange
schlange gesehen man sollte ja
eigentlich keine schlange mehr da sein
meinten meinte christoph krachten vorher
weil besser geregelt ist mit den bändern
dass das nun nicht mehr so mit metall
ist wie letztes jahr sondern aus plastik
diesmal wurde mir auch so gesagt waren
trotzdem lange schlangen kann man
natürlich nicht verhindern weil ich
lange heute da diese ja die wahrheit
ausdruck lieber tot ist nicola meter
lang bestimmt ich würde auch sagen dass
man locker 500 bis 1000 meter beste was
die stadt meldet die standen bis zum
bahnhof wo bist du so bist du was man
keine ahnung hat sich auf der treppe
wie werde ich zum block mit was du musst
rechtsklick auf was mit dem mit dem mit
dem abnehmen mit dem mit die mit dem
islam ball musst du rechtsklick auf das
macht manchmal richtig aufreißt weniger
melone auf dem dach ich bin schwein
melone offenbach ich komme zu dir
natürlich nicht mal zu dir erst wenn
nicht eine melone im haus wo bist du
kommt zum strand weggelaufen weg ja also
darf man nicht so schnell geht aber das
war auf ihre krass wie viele leute da
waren
ich habe mich ja mit firewalls schwein
bin du hast was ich bin ich bin ein
strohballen
also ich bin jetzt ein schwein und jetzt
bin ich einen tag am strand nicht schade
finde am video der über folgende sei
also da war einem mega schlange an fans
autogramme wolken kein problem ich
find's schön dass diesmal überhaupt
nicht lange gab aber im so viele leute
zusammen erstens also sozusagen wenn
jemand sagt okay ich wollte gerne
vielleicht den luca und den döner haben
keine chance saßen zwei verschiedenen
zelten und nie ein tag saßen wir
zusammen im zelt ja ja aber es
beispielsweise bei viele konstellationen
ging einfach nicht und das war einfach
schade
jedenfalls war die schlange als extrem
lang also das tut mir so kommt dafür
wollte ich mir nämlich in diesem video
einmal dafür entschuldigen
ja genau ich habe erfahren nachher als
ich hatte diese autogrammstunde am
ersten tag da war noch nicht so grunde
so eine große enttäuschung aber am
zweiten tag wo ich mit dem zeltplatz
weil dann feuerwehr da und dann ist ein
mädchen auch zusammengebrochen
dann wurden wieder abgeführt und wir
sind erst mal in dies die move zelt da
waren aber auch ganz viele fans dann
haben die security uns weitergebracht zu
also zumindest was bei revier opels und
mir so wollen wir weiter gebracht in der
messe area control da wo ich damit maxim
gebracht und dann wurden wir von da
wieder raus gebracht und dann sind wir
mit kathi von die demo von noch mit drei
anderen security und almen zweier leute
und allem vom video days rumgelaufen und
dann kam so ein mädchen hinterher
gelaufen sie ja ich habe gestern vier
stunden und heute noch mal fünf stunden
angestanden
ich komme aus österreich und ich hab ihn
so lange gefahren nur um dich und die
anderen minecraft zu sehen und ich hab
nur von irgendwie von regel sollten
autogramm bekommen von den anderen alle
nicht und dann meist die tube zu mir
schon soja hat dieser bisschen weg
geschubst wer kommt weiter nicht stehen
bleiben sonst müsstest du für jeden
stehen bleiben und dann höre ja immer
ich habe versucht so viel zu machen wie
ich konnte also ich hab dann
beispielsweise im gehen ich habe gesagt
ja tut mir leid aber kommen jetzt mit
schnellem gehen
das wollen die da hinten zwar nicht aber
mach mit ihm gehen einfach ganz schnell
ein autogramm geben und dann noch im
gehen schnell foto gemacht und alles
möglich ich habe es echt versucht wenn
wenn
oder wenn diese person sich das gerade
anschaut oder eine andere person bei der
ich versucht habe trotz der ansagen von
security & management leuten da ich
trotzdem versucht herr brecht autogramme
zu geben schreibt sie mal bitte einfach
oder falls der allgemein da ward oder
ihr könnt ihr auch einfach mal wenn ihr
euch gut geboxt
einfach mal wenn ihr lust habt könnt ihr
auch einfach mal bei instagram das ja
auch instagram ja genau ihr könnt ihr
bei instagram unter dem hashtag kontrast
oder hashtag p midcap oder herstellt
oder hersteller luca in welche hashtags
könnte ein film craft basteln oder auch
bei twitter irgendwie könnt ihr ja mal
bilder posten denn ihr
bilder mit uns gemacht hat oder
vielleicht doch mit cash und mir weil
wir zusammen im zelt saßen am samstag
ein paar sachen wenn ihr da eventuell
bilder mit uns gemacht habt dann könnt
ihr uns die ja theoretisch einfach mal
zukommen lassen das werk einer als ich
was ich noch sagen wollte er bist du
kannst diese dieser plot ja ich stehe
auf der melone
ich bin die melodie flüssigkeit in die
runde machten jahr oder mit dir ich hab
ich mehr games kriege ja ich mache ich
mir jetzt noch einmal ein feuerwerk hier
moment wenn ich das in ge capital weg
von mir dann hätten wir euch kein engel
ich habe sie alle drei feuerwerke
gezündet kann man nur 13
ja aber alle aber man ja egal jedenfalls
es war es tut das wollte ich auch sagen
es tut mir leid falls ein paar leute
keine autogramme bekommen habe selber
gesehen auf einmal wird das feld
zugemacht nach einer stunde und dann
stand da echt leute von haben griff ein
um ihr waren jüngst die außenseiter
stand bei mir oder müssen weiß wann ein
zelt vor uns dran heißt es waren
übrigens viele aussenseiter fans die am
anfang wirklich noch die außenseiter
wollten
und ja keine ahnung dann sind junge
marcel mega blöd durchplanen dass bolt
soll dass jeder sein eigenes handy also
ohne chance vielleicht genau genau genau
so genau soll ich mir doch glatt
entweder jeder kriegt ein eigenes zelt
oder einfach nach jobs dass wir noch
viel besser nach kategorien dass
beispielsweise im zelt 1 ist nur gaming
insight 210 unterhaltung im zelt drais
nur musik ins feld 40 uhr dass jeder
sein eigenes team einem endeffekt habe
ich mir am ende meint irgendein ich bin
einfach vorne pizza bude gegangen und
habe wirklich mir dort einen tisch
hinstellen lassen ein stuhl und so eine
kleine absperrung dass die leute die
sich durch gedrängelt hat zu mir dann
bequem raus gehen konnten und nicht er
sich zurückdrängen mussten und das war
das da saß ich vier stunden aber alles
tutti frutti also wurde ich mich einfach
ich muss gerade weglaufen von einem
hunter setzen ich lag aber zum
blumentopf ist natürlich schon okay ja
der ist ja auch schwer zu treffen
jetzt bin ich hier auf dem dach manchmal
wenn es auch ein flop of you cannot more
fans blockbuster kacke ich hab richtig
starkes versteck er wenn mich einer
finde dann wohl keiner zeile leiter
werden die kacke ist dass das kann ich
überhaupt werden weil da ist ein typ mit
pfeil und bogen online and side boys
werden was kann ich denn überhaupt
werden
also ja es ist hubert leid wenn viele
leute kein autogramm bekommen haben aber
es ist halt echt ein bisschen doof
gewesen jeder hatte diese eine stunde
und als ich zum beispiel am ersten tag
im zelt saß habe ich das ja angekündigt
und dann waren da echt so viele leute
und am anfang war es auch so dass die
nicht das kann ich hatte ja somit die
erste autogrammstunde da war ich mit den
baby und christ es in einem zelt und
dann haben die leute gesagt von der
security ja komm wir machen das hält er
zum nach einer stunde hätte eine stunde
und basta
aber da waren davor so viele leute haben
rom geschrieben und haben dann gerufen
security voice video der ist also dann
haben sie gesagt okay kommt man derzeit
noch mal für eine halbe stunde und
erkannt so viele leute rein gelaufen
dass wir hinter den tischen saßen total
die tisch im bauch bekommen haben und
wir sind schon so an der zeltwand also
das war total das chaos und das war
einfach richtig krass aber an allen im
all man muss immer sagen man kann es nie
allen recht machen
man gehöre ich größe gerade hier ich
habe gab es zwar ein haider getötet oha
läuft ihr also auch käfer muss echt
sagen man kann noch einiges an dieser
veranstaltung verbessern ich gehe mal
schon mal eben hier in wieder raus weil
ich bin als ob man noch einiges an
dieser veranstaltung verbessern aber ist
muss es ist auf jeden fall das muss man
sagen man muss dafür bedanken dass es so
was gibt ihnen das heute so etwas planen
und ich will dass das so es ist besser
geworden zu einem must nächsten märz
wieder besser werden man lernt ja auch
aus seinen fehlern
ja und was ich schön finde der video der
ist ja ein event was nur für youtuber
und die fans da ist oder er
hauptsächlich für die fans weil da
stehen die fans im mittelpunkt und
deswegen finde ich das eigentlich cool
genau so nenne ich was für dieser video
der bringen wenn da nicht 14.000 leute
von euch da gewesen wären
da gewesen als jetzt gar nicht war also
das lebt quasi alles von euch und allein
diese entwicklung auch das haben die
auch in diesem in dieser schau da gesagt
irgendwie vor zwei jahren das war mein
erster video data war es in einer
kleinen messe halle von der gamescom
da waren irgendwie 400 leute da dann ein
jahr später war's auch schon die räder
da war irgendwie 5000 leute da dieses
jahr waren 14.000 leute angekündigt und
das ist so krank dass da einfach nur man
muss ja mal vorstellen ich mein paar
leute simon zum beispiel hat jetzt
irgendwie eine million abonnenten und da
sind noch 14.000 leute und der hat quasi
alle leute die da waren mal zehn als
zuschauer das ist so krank mal 100 sogar
mal 100 das ist so krass also wenn man
sich das ganze mal überlegt wie was für
ausmaße das mittlerweile hat uns wird
auch gesagt so stellt euch mal vor ihr
habt beispielsweise 500.000 abonnenten
und ich sitze jetzt nur quatschen was
immer mikrofon und wenn man sich mal
jetzt ehrlich vor 500.000 leute
hinstellen würde und so was sagen würde
wird man sich jeden satz zum anders
überlegen erstelle dir mal wirklich voll
gemein hannover hat ja 400.000 500.000
einwohner mit umland und allem alles was
wir hier sagen weiß gesamt hannover das
heißt jeden menschen den ich in meinem
gesamten leben bisher getroffen habe in
dieser stadt
wer weiß bescheid das kann man sich gar
nicht vorstellen das ist echt krass so
jeder der die auf der straße begegnet im
sommer großstadt kennt dich das ist
verrückt wenn ich das mal nachdenkt ist
das echt krank aber ich gehe auf jeden
fall noch mal vor allen bedanken die da
waren entschuldigen an alle denen ich
keine autogramme geben konnte als irgend
unterbunden wurde und sonst würde ich
sagen man sieht es ja noch auf anderen
veranstaltungen oder event macht man
nochmal fantreffen oder sonst nächstes
jahr soll es ja eventuell in berlin sein
dass der video data gemunkelt und
sonstwie seinen dank an kräfte mit dabei
weil es eine beschreibung verlinkt und
wir sehen uns dann im nächsten video
wieder zu